well it's finally over
Logan Paul apologized coffeezilla your
slime is he is a lopsided journalist
with an agenda more like an internet
criminal oops wrong video that was the
first response he actually apologized in
another response
the defamation lawsuit that is happening
because this is wrong this is
hold on wait a second that's not it
either uh turns out it's actually on his
secondary Channel that's why I couldn't
find it it's entitled thank you
coffeezilla it's the third response from
Logan Paul and it's a pretty big change
in Logan's attitude so far so let's see
what he has to say to us coffee Zilla is
not a criminal oh that's a relief I
thought Logan was gonna hire me but in
all seriousness this video does have
some major admissions in it I want to go
through for one Logan apologizes to me I
called him I apologized my initial
response to his series was that of of a
fire uh an ego not only that Logan also
pledges a 1.3 million dollar refund plan
for people who bought his nfts I am
personally committing a thousand each to
this which is about 1.3 million dollars
in addition to the that he also promises
to finish cryptozu which was left
abandoned and then step three obviously
finish and deliver the game as outlined
in the white paper now I'll be honest
this is a big change in tone and
honestly a lot of this is good news it's
great that victims are going to get
something back Logan seems to
acknowledge his continuous lapse in
judgment he's not suing me which is also
cool and frankly this new response is
just uh way better than his last two I
think we can all acknowledge that while
also acknowledging that it's not really
a perfect response either there are
still major problems here like for
example many of the victims just have
been ignored in this response a lot of
accusations have gone unanswered and
worse Logan still seems to be playing
the victim a lot so in this video I'm
gonna do my best to give Logan credit
where credit is absolutely due while
also sharing moments where I think this
apology fell flat and let me start with
a positive for example I think if you
are an outsider who is not affected by
this scam and you wanted a reason to
love Logan Paul again I think this Nails
it I mean he's giving back some of the
money he's apologizing so if you're a
card-carrying member of the low gang you
can rest easy here Logan says he's sorry
he says he's making things right and I
think that's the point of this video is
to speak to his core audience to tell
them he didn't scam anyone and for what
it's worth I think Logan succeeds here
the problem is I don't think I or the
crypto Zoo holders were who Logan was
really addressing here and this is where
the response Falls more flat because he
doesn't adequately address the real
victims of crypto Zoo which I I think
they're rightfully angry about and I
wanted to spend some time talking about
that because again they've been the
heartbeat of this whole story and they
feel very differently about this
response than Logan's core audience does
they don't feel like it's enough and I
want to talk about why starting with the
1.3 million dollars repayment plan
because obviously this is the strong
longest part of Logan's entire response
actually opening up his wallet and I
don't want to minimize that in this
video I just do want to put it in
context because 1.3 million dollars is a
lot of money unfortunately the scam was
much bigger than 1.3 million dollars so
the fact is most victims are not going
to be made whole by this plan just in
zoo coins alone blockchain evidence
shows 7.7 million dollars was stolen by
Logan's team depending on who you
believe and this refund does nothing for
those victims it doesn't even apply to
the holder of zoo coins at all you get
nothing if you bought this in-game
currency this refund only applies to
current egg holders so they can cash out
that nft for the initial mint price in
crypto which matters sort of because
crypto has crashed a lot so even though
people spent 2.5 million dollars on
these eggs in order to refund all these
holders at mint price it now only costs
1.3 million dollars in in today's money
which again is nice but doesn't do
enough because the zoo coins were most
of this scam I mean that's where most of
the money was spent wasn't just on the
nfts it was on this in-game currency
which Logan seems to have no intention
of refunding and his response for why is
pretty bad he responds to somebody who
lost eighty thousand dollars who told
him I hope this isn't just doing what
you have to do technically to not get
sued Logan replies with a screenshot of
his white paper and later explains to
another member of the Discord I believe
there has been a misconception here as
outlined in the white paper zoo was
created to support cryptozoo and was not
intended to be an investment vehicle
when you sold or bought is not my
decision and look to be fair to him
there was a misconception that zoo was
an investment vehicle but it's a
misconception that he created I mean
he's the one who said kryptos who was a
fun game that earns you money and how it
earned you that money was that your nfts
earned you Zoot tokens you know things
that were supposed to have value that
was the whole point of the game so to
suggest that these coins weren't
advertised as valuable or an investment
vehicle is insane especially since
Logan's own team had rules for selling
based strictly on the value of said
investment vehicle quote rules for
selling no selling until a 200 million
dollar market cap so I think it's fair
to say if Logan's own team were buying
Zoo coins early waiting for them to go
up in value to a certain level and then
selling them that sounds like an
investment vehicle albeit a very stupid
one so this explanation definitely
doesn't hold water and Logan obviously
just doesn't want to be on the hook for
Zoo coins instead he just kind of wants
to refund the much smaller part of the
nfts what makes this even worse is that
this refund doesn't even apply to
everyone who bought these nfts because
some of these people sold their nfts at
a deep loss thinking that crypto zoo was
over that it was abandoned and and
there's actually a way you could have
tracked this whole thing or Logan could
have and you know found a way to repay
all the people who lost money on eggs
but instead this refund only applies to
current holders meaning nobody who sold
during the year and a half this project
was abandoned gets anything back which
is a large percentage of the actual
victims and this is pretty bad this was
brought to Logan's attention by one of
the people in the Discord joao says
quote Logan Paul what will happen to the
people who sold everything at a loss
when the project appeared to be quote
abandoned well everyone who minted be
able to get that refund or just the
current owners now in reply to this
someone in the Discord said if you sell
you lose common investing knowledge and
Logan replies seeming to agree with this
idea which is just kind of a terrible
perspective for Logan to have when he
seems to be saying that he wants to
refund these people and he's the reason
a lot of these people left and this is
where Logan's new apology starts to ring
more Hollow a it's in all of the
follow-ups after the response video
because I don't know if he can help
himself from betraying how he really
feels about this because in another
Discord exchange Logan says please do
not put any more money into cryptozoo
which by the way is quite reasonable to
say but then somebody follows up and
says guys can someone explain what he
said with not investing but rather than
replying oh guys I just meant like I
don't want anyone else losing money or
you know I don't want anyone else
recklessly gambling Logan replies
instead quote I will no longer be the
scapegoat for anyone's financial
decisions which is a wild response for
someone who's claiming to refund people
because it implies that he thinks he's
the victim here and this is just insane
to say as the face of this project which
got everyone involved because I think it
betrays how he feels about this
situation he doesn't seem to see
anything wrong with advertising a game
that will make you money it never
delivering millions of dollars being
stolen by criminals he hired and then
when all of those people want their
money back he feels like he's the
scapegoat like oh these guys shouldn't
have believed me when I advertised to
them a fun game that will make you money
it just doesn't make any sense I mean
Logan had a simple job to do all he had
to do was just come out apologize get as
much money back for the victims as
possible but he himself can't help but
play the victim here in fact I have a
third example of how Logan might really
feel because Logan tweeted right before
this response he says quote The Matrix
is real pray you never become its Target
now I guess he's trying to channel
Andrew Tate here unsuccessfully
basically saying like ah I'm getting
attacked not because I did anything
wrong or scammed anyone I'm just I'm
just too much of a truth teller I'm just
an enemy of the system that's why I must
be getting attacked but if that's the
case we didn't have to wonder did The
Matrix force you to apologize did it
force you to hand back 1.3 million I
just think comments like this go so far
to undercut his apology because it's
very clear that instead of actually like
caring about the victims he feels like
he's a victim I mean he's saying like oh
pray you never become its Target who's
the Matrix though Logan like is it your
fans who got robbed who are the agents
coming after you I I know it's not me I
know you're not saying I'm the Matrix
here in my 10 million dollar Studio
because after all you're thanking me
you're thinking the Matrix like what is
this response it's so childish the way
he speaks about this stuff and again
this isn't to be dismissive of Logan's
actions if he follows through because
there is a lot of good that 1.3 million
can do and you know what if he goes back
and he finishes the game that's also
good but it's just so frustrating when
the good that Logan seems to be doing
he's doing the bare minimum of at the
last possible second with motivations
that seem to be in the proper context to
say it lightly irreparably tainted by
self-interest now I'm not going to
address Logan's other two response
videos which are mostly like attacking
me because Logan sort of walked those
back now he's apologized he said he was
going to delete them I think he deleted
one of them the other one's still up I
don't know if the impulsive episode's
gonna go down either way it's just much
less interesting now that he says he
doesn't like mean it anymore he's not
gonna Sue so I don't feel the need to
publicly defend myself if you're curious
about all the wild stuff that was wrong
in those first two responses
um I'll put the video live on my patreon
but I didn't want to release it at the
time because I thought there was a
better chance at getting a good ending
for the victims here if I was a bit more
diplomatic with Logan at this critical
juncture when he was deciding whether he
was going to give money back or not I
don't know if I succeeded in moving the
needle but that was certainly my
intention either way now that Logan has
responded with his plan and I've given
my perspective on how much I think it's
rooted in you know self-interest versus
a genuine you know attempt to help out
the the victims I think this is about as
much as I'm going to be able to
contribute to this situation I mean I do
think it's incredible that even 1.3
million dollars came of this while I
also can acknowledge that it's not
nearly enough for the real victims of
this I'll follow up in the future to
make sure that he actually gives that
money away but for now I think most of
the crypto Zoo victims if they're still
hungry for justice are going to have to
take it up with Logan in ways that are
different than I can do on YouTube here
which by the way I think some of them
are in fact I just saw a lawyer on
YouTube uh attorney Tom he's going to
start the legal process going after
Logan using stuff like the arbitration
clause in their terms of service so I
just wanted to say if you're a victim of
cryptozoo you can check out that video
which I'll link to you if you want or
consult with a lawyer because I'm sure
for the people who lost a lot of money
this is certainly not the end for them
because they didn't get a full refund
and I'm sure they'll be seeking one but
even though it's not the end for them it
is the end for me for now this is the
end of the crypto Zoo Saga and I wanted
to say and give a huge heartfelt thank
you to everyone who viewed this and
supported me throughout this it's been
insane the level of support when Logan
was threatening us and I do not take it
lightly there is an alternate universe
where if that hadn't happened Logan
would feel emboldened to sue me and
probably not give much back to the
victims so it's your support that made
all the difference and got the victims
at least something
so that wraps it up thank you for
watching